five four three two rehearsals
business insider oh this sounds exciting
in 1969 our
founders joan cooney and and lloyd
morissette had the revolutionary idea
of asking what if kids can learn from tv
they had noticed that kids could uh
repeat beer jingles
[Music]
so
they posed themselves that question and
basically uh created sesame street which
is a show that's now been on the air
almost 50 years we film at kaufman
astoria studios which is in astoria
queens and is a you know very old studio
that was built in the 20s by what was
united artists at the time and has gone
through
many iterations over the years on a
regular production day like today when
you're visiting there's about 60 people
involved when you count the production
staff that's downstairs in the office as
well as all of the technical and stage
crew and camera people and costume
designers etc it really does take a
village to bring this show together
every year when we start a new season
what we do is our curriculum team
convenes an all-day seminar and they
basically consult with experts in child
development child psychology preschool
teachers
as the writers work the curriculum team
works in tandem with the production team
and they review all the scripts and and
give feedback from the educational
standpoint uh we also do a lot of
research so we'll take some of the
scripts into into schools we'll read
them to the kids and and solicit
feedback from them our production cycle
is essentially a 12-month cycle you know
from from the moment of that curriculum
seminar which i described to the moment
we deliver shows to hbo jim henson you
know obviously his impact on sesame
street is is massive and uh
he was the one who brought the muppets
to
sesame street
and so his legacy i mean is is very
solid and lives on on the show because
all of our puppeteers are trained
basically in a methodology that he
invented
i mean he took the puppet theater
and decided i'm going to get rid of that
and just use the tv frame as my puppet
theater
while looking at a monitor so that i can
position my puppet and see exactly what
i need to see and so basically he
invented you know puppetry for
television
and our puppeteers are trained in in
those methods that he came up with it
truly is like kind of a magic act so we
have a core group of puppeteers that's
uh is 14 people 14 performers we we have
a mentee program that we run to identify
new puppeteers and so there's a few of
those and we'll bring them in a day here
a day there there's essentially three
three categories of puppets there's the
walk around puppet so that's big bird or
snuffy for example where the person is
inside the puppet and they're operating
it from from inside it's a full suit
you and me together old pal
then there's what we call a bag puppet
so that's like cookie monster or the
count
one two
three
four and so there the puppet covers the
puppeteer the puppeteer is operating the
mouth with one hand and is operating one
of the hands with another and then
there's a second puppeteer which we
usually call the assistant puppeteer
and that person comes behind and
operates the other hand and helps hand
props from below frame then the third
kind of puppet is what we call a rod
puppet so that's like an elmo or an
abbey
and so they have those are typically
operated by a single puppeteer they hold
two rods which operate the hands and
then they're operating the mouth this
way the primary puppeteer is always the
person that does the voice
so the the most recent and probably most
talked about
uh for the us is julia who's a young
girl who's on the autism spectrum
can big bird see your painting
see your painting
yes and she was developed originally by
our uh social impact team another
example on the international side
because we do a lot of international
work is uh zari who was developed for
afghanistan to the street thank you elmo
damn so excited to be here
she's six years old she's
curious
and also has a younger brother who looks
up to her which is a great kind of
gender equity role modeling
carol spinney has been here since
season one um you know and and is the
originator of both oscar and big bird
he's obviously a legend and an amazing
performer and just an amazing guy
we have a couple of crew members believe
it or not who've been here for nearly 50
years
frankie who's our camera one operator
has been here since the beginning
our sound effects editor
dick maitland has also been here since
the beginning they work on sesame street
because they love sesame street they
believe in our mission so people tend to
stay in a given season of 35 episodes
we'll have you know 10 to 12 celebrity
appearances uh we love to do musical
guests because kids love music
and you know it's a the celebrities are
are for the parents and and uh you know
more so than the kids who may not know
who john legend is but but uh
when we can combine both do a musical
and a celebrity appearance then it's
great for everyone celebrities will
reach out to us especially if they've
recently had kids and they think to
themselves wow i would love for junior
to see me on tv
sesame street has changed a lot and our
production models evolve with new
technology all the time
so we did a big
kind of redesign of the set in season 46
so that was about four years ago and and
it was uh
you know obviously we kept one two three
the brownstone and hoopers those are
those are the touchstones of the set but
we wanted to to modernize it some to to
give it a more colorful and vibrant uh
atmosphere and also to position the
puppets
in in specific places so abby who is a
fairy we put her in her garden and so
now every kid who watches sesame street
knows like that's abby's garden that's
where she lives that's that's where she
hangs out and plays with her friends
there's hundreds of studies that have
shown the effectiveness of sesame street
and and how kids who watch sesame street
are ready for school
in a fashion that's greater than those
who don't why me love cookies
oh they just the perfect food
they ground
they crunchy they soft in the middle
they chocolate
chocolate
sorry we got to go get the cookie right
now excuse me